I'm Bo KS from freec camp.org and in
this course I'm going to show you how
you can use AI to make it simpler to
deploy infrastructure and websites when
creating and deploying using
infrastructures Code it can sometimes be
hard to keep track of all the
configuration properties and what
functions and commands you need to use
well now artificial intelligence can
help you with all of those things I'll
be showing you how to use AI tools
created by palumi palumi provided a
grant to make the course possible first
I'll demonstrate how to create a simple
web project so you can quickly grasp the
power of these AI tools then I'll
explain more about infrastructure as
code and show you the basics of using
palumi after that I'll demonstrate how
it's possible to use palumi AI to
develop infrastructure even if you don't
know the exact steps yourself and
finally I'll demonstrate how you can use
AI to help you search through all of
your infrastructure resources to make it
simpler for you to make updates okay
let's get started I'm going to show you
how to use the plumi AI to quickly spin
up an S3 bucket and create a website I'm
just going to be showing a quick example
right now but later in this course I'll
show you some a lot more complicated
examples on how to use palumi AI for
infrastructures code but right now I'll
just do MPX plumi AI now I previously
already set up palumi on my computer and
also attached AWS to palumi I'll have a
link to the instructions for how to do
that in the description so now what what
do I want to build well I want to build
an S3
bucket and I can just use normal English
it's also connecting to chat GPT or the
open AI API to be able to handle U plain
English but then it also is able to
connect with plumy and I just created a
bucket if I go over to my AWS console
and we see the bucket it's right in the
console now okay now that we have the
bucket let's add something to the bucket
so add an index.html file with a simple
number guessing
game okay now I'm just going to ask what
is the
URL
okay now I can just copy this
URL and access denied that's actually
easy enough to fix I can go into my
bucket here it's just because of the
permissions they get set by default to
block all public access so I'll just
unblock Public
Access and then I'll go to index.html
set the permission of
this and then we'll also go down
here and do ACL
enabled then we can edit this so we'll
have read and
list and then if I go to objects
we can make public using
ACL now you may not have to do all that
if you already had it set up beforehand
um so depending on how you have AWS set
up palumi can just make it public by
default but if you don't have it set up
correctly like I didn't have it set up
you may have to manually make everything
public okay let me just go to the
website again now in this one it just
made it so I don't actually get have to
enter the the number I just have to keep
clicking try it until we get the right
number actually I don't think that
code's working at all so let's see if we
can update the code redo the
complete number guessing
game from
scratch now yeah you usually you're not
going to be having it code something
from this uh you'll be having it create
uh infrastructure but I just want to
kind of show this example of how it can
actually create a code as well you're
just going to have to experiment with it
if you're going to actually create a
website like this and you can also have
it say oh add styling and then it can
add extra styling to the website but now
let's just move on to something else in
this section I'll give a brief overview
of infrastructure's code after that I'll
review the basics of palumi and finally
I'll demonstrate how to use AI to
simplify and streamline your
infrastructures code feel free to skip
ahead if you you already know the basics
of infrastructure as code so
infrastructure as code is the practice
of managing and provisioning
infrastructure through machine readable
definition files rather than using
fysical Hardware configuration or
interactive configuration tools in the
era of cloud computing infrastructure as
code plays a pivotal role in ensuring
that infrastructure is consistent
repeatable and
scalable traditionally infrastructure
was man managed manually with system
administrators configuring each server
individually as the scale of operations
grew this approach became inefficient
and error prone the need for automation
led to the birth of configuration
management tools and the concept of
infrastructure as code here's some of
the key Concepts and principles behind
infrastructure as code the first is item
potent this means the ability to run the
same code multiple times without
changing the result after the first
run the next concept is
immutability infrastructure components
are never modified after they're
deployed if changes are needed new
infrastructure is provisioned and old
ones are discarded the final key
principle is declarative versus the
imperative approach while a declarative
approach specifies the desired instate
like I want a server an imperative
approach specifies the steps to achieve
the end State like create a server then
install software x with infrastructure's
code infrastructure changes are made in
a systematic repeatable manner reducing
manual errors it also allows for Version
Control ensuring that all team members
are working with the same configurations
some of the popular infrastructure as
code tools are terraform
which is a tool that allows users to
Define infrastructure's code using a
declarative configuration language that
is a proprietary domain specific
language anle is an open-source
automation tool for configuration
management application deployment and
task automation chef and puppet are
configuration management tools that
allow infrastructure to be defined as
code and automated palumi is an open-
Source tool that offers the flexibility
to use any programming l language for
managing infrastructure this makes
palumi widely accessible to developers
and devops Engineers from any background
and we'll be talking more about palumi
later some of the best practices for
infrastructures code are to modularize
configurations to ensure they are
reusable regularly test and validate
infrastructure as code scripts to ensure
they work as expected and document
configurations for clarity and future
reference let's just quickly look at a
code example for infrastructure is code
we we'll be going through code more in
detail later I just want you to see that
this is how you would use palumi to set
up ec2 instances in adws using python
the infrastructures code offers numerous
benefits it's essential to manage secret
securely ensure infrastructure security
and handle potential infrastructure
drift where the actual state diverges
from the desired state infrastructure's
code is revolutionizing the way we think
about and managed infrastructure as the
tech landscape continues to evolve
adopting infrastructure as code and
staying updated with its best practices
will be crucial for organizations aiming
for efficiency and
scalability now let's take a deep dive
into palumi so what is palumi palumi is
an infrastructures code platform
designed for developers and Cloud
Engineers who want to use general
purpose programming languages to Define
and manage Cloud resources ources unlike
traditional infrastructures code tools
that use domain specific languages
palumi allows users to leverage popular
programming languages such as go
JavaScript or typescript python andn net
platforms palumi works with traditional
infrastructure like VMS networks and
databases in addition to Modern
architectures including containers
kubernetes clusters and serverless
functions plumi supports dozens of cloud
service providers we'll be using Python
and deploying on AWS though it can be
done with other programming languages in
Cloud providers let's look at the key
components of palumi one is provider
sdks these are installable packages that
your program consumes plumi supports
over 75 providers with new ones being
added
regularly the command line interface is
a tool that users can use to run
previews and updates on their
infrastructure
programs the service backend is the
default State Storage service for all
plumi projects it stores a snapshot of
the state of your resources known as the
checkpoint every time you update your
Cloud resources using
palumi so let's look at how plumi works
it works by processing the code written
in one of the supported languages and
generating a graph of the resources that
need to be created updated or deleted
this graph is then used to calculate the
of crud operations required to achieve
the desired state of the infrastructure
here are some of the key features the
component resources these are resources
that encapsulate multiple child
resources allowing users to represent
several related resources as a single
unit stack references this feature
allows users to create multiple stacks
and consume the outputs exported by
other Upstream Stacks Dynamic providers
this feature serves as an escape hatch
for when there's no offici provider for
a resource automation API this API
allows users to programmatically invoke
CLI operations enabling Advanced
deployment
scenarios palumi insights brings
intelligence to Cloud infrastructure
using plumi it includes features like
plumi AI which is a generative AI
assistant built to create Cloud
infrastructure using natural language
and plumey resource search which offers
multicloud search and analytics across
every cloud res source and environment
in the in know organization soon I'll be
showing how to use both of these tools
with the introduction of new CLI
commands palumi insights is now more
accessible to users allowing them to
leverage Ai and resource search directly
from the terminal poi's program model
starts with the plumi project at the
outermost layer however users don't
often interact directly with these
projects they're typically created when
initializing a plumey program and tend
to disappear when the last stack within
the project is
destroyed inside the project there is a
program which is the main entry point
for the program if you're using
typescript this is
index.ts so that would be the prog the
main program this is where we Define our
infrastructure the infrastructure is
characterized by palumi
resources an example of a palumi
resource is an AWS S3 bucket such
resources have been have both inputs and
outputs for instance specifying a
bucket's name would be an input while
the bucket's Amazon resource name or Arn
would be an output a reoccurring pattern
you'll notice in a palumi program is how
the output of one resource becomes the
input for another if you have an S3
bucket and wish to Divine a policy for
it the Arn output of the bucket will
serve as an input to the bucket policy
behind the scenes plumi manages the
dependencies between these resources
ensuring they are set up or taken down
efficiently it also keeps track of the
sequence in which operations need to be
executed in addition to the program
there's also the concept of stacks a
stack is essentially an instance of your
palumi program with the added
flexibility of supplying different
configuration values for different
instances this is useful when you want
to have separate setups for development
QA and production environments for
instance in a development environment
you might opt for fewer or less powerful
ec2 instances compared to a production
environment this differentiation is
achieved using stack
configuration discussing Plum's physical
architecture at the foundational level
we have our palumi
programs these programs can be written
in various languages such as python
typescript JavaScript go c f and Java
plumi also offers support for yaml
mainly for larger organizations
transitioning to pumat scale this option
caters to those with traditional
operations with traditional operations
experience who might find it more
comfortable working with yaml than with
standard programing
languages the palumi engine interprets
your palumi program the palumi engine
works by comparing your palumi programs
desired state with the existing state as
recorded in your state file it
identifies the discrepancies between the
two and determines which resources need
to be created updated or deleted this
process is facilitated through palumi
providers for instance in our example we
mentioned the palumi AWS s provider and
the kubernetes provider these providers
offer support for a multitude of public
clouds softwares of service providers
and other platforms this vast array of
providers ensures that users can
leverage palumi declarative approach to
manage resources across a broad spectrum
of services now I'll give a brief
example on how to use plumi and then
we'll see how to use the AI features
we'll start with a blank directory and
we'll initialize a plumi program using
the plumey new
command upon executing this command
there's a lot of templates that are
displayed uh there's a bunch there's 221
and I'm going to just go to the static
website
AWS typescript so this is just a
typescript program to deploy stch
website on
AWS so I'm going to put
um
typescript AWS for the project name uh
default project description default
stack name uh I'll just use this region
which is actually pretty close to me Us
West
2 and the rest of this we'll
just keep as
default so these prompts are specific to
this template because it set up sets up
a static site post initialization the
system runs an mpm install which will be
familiar to anyone experienced with
node.js now I after installation our
project direct directory reveals several
files and folders We have a node modules
folder where noj stores the pendency a
www folder created by the template to
house our website files the get ignore
file but first let's discuss the plum.
yaml
file this file contains project
configuration details remember when we
use the pumi new command and provided
certain inputs well those responses are
saved in this file additionally we have
a plumi dod. yaml which is the stack
configuration for deploying our static
site to different regions we can create
separate Stacks with their respective
configuration files so let's move on to
the
index.ts file let me move that down here
this is the core of our plumi program it
begins with importing libraries like the
the the plumi
SDK and which allows us to access our
values from our configuration file and
also the AWS
provider uh which it's going to create
AWS resources and a palumi component
called sync folder to synchronize a
folder with our Object
Store this file Al also demonstrates the
pattern of using the output of one
resource as the input of another
resource so I'm not going to go through
this file in complete detail but you can
see how it's creating a three bucket
it's configuring the ownership controls
configuring the ACL block and it's using
the sync folder that we talked about
creating a cloud CDN to distribute the
the cast on the website so this is just
the template and we can basically modify
this template how we want and then it's
just going to export the URLs and host
names of the bucket and distribution
in this example an S3 buckets details
like its ownership controls might
reference another resource the file this
file proceeds to define various
resources related to the bucket and set
up the sync folder to mirror the content
of our www folder with the S3 bucket and
establishes a cloudfront distribution
and then uh like we already talked about
here this is when it ends with defining
the stack outputs using a Standard
typescript Export statement allowing
external access to certain values from
our palumi program so to see the to to
see the impact of the configurations we
will use the palumi up command so let me
go back to the console here and we'll do
palumi up this stands for update the
command previews the changes before our
actual execution ensuring that we're
aware of the actions plumi plans to take
so this is where it will confirm whether
we want to perform the update and I'll
go to yes that is what we want to do so
after we get this all done we can check
the website so here's the URL and I'm
just going to follow the link and it
works hello plumy or hello world
deployed by
palumi let me show you one more thing
really quick let's see what happens if I
make a change so like for instance I can
go here and I'm going to change the
default TTL to
300 and then I'll just save that and
then I'll just do pumi up
again and you'll see that it will not
recreate every resource it only makes
the update this is what it means that
palumi is declarative I'll say I do want
to perform the update you just say your
desired State and plumi will figure out
what needs to be
updated and then finally we can use the
palumi
destroy if I can spell it right destroy
command to tear down the
resources that way we won't incur any
more charges so yes I do want to destroy
this and that will just lead everything
off of
AWS so if I just go back to the page and
refresh uh there's nothing there we get
the 403
Forbidden but now I'm going to go to a
different page plum.com
we're going to talk about palumi ai
palumi ai is accessible at plum.com
it's free for everyone to use within the
plumi ecosystem there are over 130
providers some of these providers like
AWS offer more more than a thousand
resources on average each of these
resources might have around 30
configuration properties given the vast
number of potential configurations it
can sometimes be challenging to set
everything up perfectly this is where
plumi AI proves
useful so to demonstrate I'll just put
a basic um prompt here I'm going to say
show me how to run engine X as an ECS
far
gate task in the
default
VPC so this is a natural language
prompt and you see I just I chose
typescript as a preferred language but I
could have chosen a a different
language
and you can see it's just generating the
program it took a minute to process so
you can Al you can see often begins the
response by echoing the initial the
initial prompt re question that creates
an internal feedback loop which enhances
the quality of the solution provided and
we can see everything that it suggests
like using the ECS cluster um it create
it creates an ECS task definition and it
creates a fargate service and it
basically goes through and and does what
we asked it to do it and then it
basically summarizes what it's going to
do and then it just gives you some some
different things that you can change you
can place inex latest with any Docker
image of your choice it's been in your
owns
um account and then it just kind of
explains it even more so we can just
copy this and then I can put it right
into
here and then you can see there are some
some squiggly lines here so this is an
iterative process basically it's not
uncommon to encounter some
errors and these tools while powerful
might not always yield perfect results
so users should expect some degree of
iteration and
refinement so I can look right here it
says property
quick so I can actually just copy
this
and I will bring in here and I'll
say
error and I'll just paste in the
error and now it's going to fix it for
me it's going to update
it and it realiz it realizes that in
more recent versions of plumi the test
definition should be created differently
okay so now just copy this updated
code Oops I did not copy it right let's
try that again click that copy
button okay so now we don't have the the
red squiggle lines there and you can see
we could just go through that with all
of them and just telling it what's wrong
and having it fix having it fix the
error so basically we can go back and
forth like I said it's an iterative
process and while it may not produce
Flawless results on the first try they
can provide an excellent starting point
often around 80% accurate which
significantly reduces the time and
effort required these tools are
especially beneficial when task with
recalling specific configurations or
procedures that aren't routinely used
for example if one needs to draft an I
am policy to access a secret but doesn't
remember the exact steps tools like
plumey AI can provide a quick and
accurate solution plumey AI is a
powerful tool that can
significantly uh expedite the learning
and applications of coding tasks so now
let's try a more complex example
and then we'll follow through to
creating the actual resources here here
we're not going to actually run this
program but this next one we will so I'm
going to go over here and I'm just going
to create a new conversation by just
going to plum.com aai
again so now I want to create a
serverless function chain basically I
want to deploy a series of serverless
functions that trigger each other in a
specific order basically AWS Lambda
functions that trigger another Lambda
function and so on so the kind of
architecture I'm looking to create is
ideal for sequential tasks where one
processes outcome determines the
subsequent processes input now we're
just going to do a very simple function
change it wouldn't be like it's not
going to be like a real world situation
but I can give you an example of of what
you can do with with plume AI uh
function chains are which sometimes
called function pipelines or sequences
can streamline multi-step processes by
allowing the output of one function to
serve as input to the next um some some
like real applications that if they're
used for would be an e-commerce order
processing where stages like order
validation payment and and inventory
updates occur sequentially and data data
analytics where RW data undergo stages
of cleansing transformation and Analysis
um also maybe like user registration
workflows document approval systems uh
financial transaction monitoring so when
you have a modular workflow it can offer
flexibility scalability and ease of
troubleshooting as each function can be
just individually managed and
optimized so like I said our this going
be a simple function chain the first
function will check the character count
if the character count is correct the
second function will be triggered which
and the second function will turn all
the characters to capital letters and
Trigger the third function which will
save the text submission so uh the truth
is I don't even even though it's simple
I don't personally fully know how to do
this so we're going to use plumey AI to
help
us okay so let's see if let's just try
this and see if we can figure this out
so I'll say help me create a
L an AWS
Lambda function chain that
processes
text the first
function will check character
count if the character count is more
than 50 and less less
than
1,000 then the second
function is
triggered the
second
function will turn the
characters to capital
letters and
trigger a
third
function the the final function will
save the
text on
AWS okay let's just see what I can
figure out from this
instruction okay it's creating a chain
of L A Lambda functions that c describe
text processing operation ations
checking the link of string transforming
the text and saving the result to an S3
bucket so it's going to even develop the
program structure create three AWS
Lambda
functions uh each function is written in
jws and embed directly in the plumi
program so we don't have to store them
elsewhere create an API Gateway to serve
as a trigger to start the Lambda
function chaining upon request to the
API Gateway the first Lambda executes it
checks the length of the input text L is
adequate the link ciruit invokes the cap
Caper function that converts the
characters to uppercase and the
capitalizer function then invokes the
saver function that saves the modified
text on3 bucket then the final URL to
trigger the workflow is
exported okay so that's exactly what we
wanted so let's see what it came up
with so we have the link cheor Lambda
and it's going to create that you can
see it's checking for the length of the
it uses the 50 and the 1,000 just like
like we
said and then it's going to invoke the
capital it's going to invoke the
capitalizer
function so let's see the capitalizer
the capitalizer Lambda
function it's going
to do the two
uppercase then it's going to invoke the
saver
function and the saver
function is going to save to an S3
bucket it may not work exactly right at
the first try but let's just check
that copy the
code I'm just going to paste it right in
here and then just try to figure out
what the errors are
so I can actually just copy this error
here and it says the argument of type
runtime is not assignable to a parameter
of type function
args okay so let's just copy this error
and then we're going to go back over
here and I'll paste it
in so let's see what it figures
out now it knows that we need the RO
properties specify the I am
roll and the aw Lambda assumes when it
executes your function on let's add a
new IM rooll for each of your Lambda
functions and that sets up the IM
permissions okay we may have to do some
more permissions uh change the
permissions within AWS as well but let's
try
this okay so now it's not we don't have
as many red squiggly
lines so oh
okay
we okay I see there's something wrong
here because it's assuming it says the
rest of your Lambda configuration
here so I'm going to go back
here um can you output the
full
code that I
need and then I'll
say
um do
not just
say
actually put the config the
config now we I could Pro I think I just
need to combine these two code together
which I could do manually but I'm going
to see if it can do
that I'm going to skip a little the back
and forth so you can see the result this
is an iterative process to get to the
correct code and I came into this
knowing very little about how to
implement this project it was so much
quicker using palumi AI okay so we have
the URL here 1 2 3 my name is Bo my name
is B my name is Bo and let's see if it
works okay Ted we got the length here
but let's see if the capitalize words
are now stored in our S3 bucket okay
okay here's our bucket and file.
txt let's download it and it worked see
I just added that one two three and all
the letters are in capital
letters we did it we made a function
chain from one to the other to the other
and again I had never done anything like
this before but I was able to use palumi
AI to figure
out this is awesome and now I feel so
much more empowered to be able to create
basically any sort of infrastructure as
code now that I have palumi ai to help
out now let's see how we can search
through our infrastructure resources and
how AI can make the process easier so
after you've created tons of stacks and
resources it can become it can become
challenging to manage and keep track
them all so let me show you how that can
become easier well here's the plumey
cloud dashboard and you can see it's
going to show how many members are in
the organization you usually going to
have more than one uh number of stacks
and then the number of resources for big
organizations the number of resources
can be thousands or even hundreds of
thousands of resources which can lead
users to question the relevance of these
resources or what the origin is or
whether you need to clean some of them
up so we can use the resource the
resource search feature uh when you're
managing a large organization with many
individuals working on various Stacks
the resource the resource search feature
is
invaluable uh when you're on this this
main dashboard you can see uh the
overview I was talking about you can
even see like when the last stack was
updated but if I click on
resources then we can search through all
the
resources so you can see it just has a
list of all the resources on every
stack and there's just a bunch of them
and I can just uh search for things like
I can search for API and then it will
show everything that has the has API in
it or I could search
for kubernetes
just brings up one thing that's related
to kubernetes here and you can search
for things by name
capitalizer and then we can see all the
functions that have or all the resources
that have the word capitalizer we also
have the advanced
filtering uh this provides aggregate
information about resources we can
search by various criteria like I can do
everything that has to do with
AWS or um here this will make it look a
little better I can do everything that
has plumia providers AWS so that's the
type and then I can say all that type in
this project and so I can further narrow
down based on the type the packages
projects or the stacks and you may have
a lot more depending on how many
resources you have so the search
function is very is very
versatile I'll just look
for all the Lambda
functions so the powerful search syntax
allows us users to make very complex
queries but there's also an integrated
AI assistant so if I click here I can
switch using palumi
Ai and this can help users craft queries
which makes the search process even more
userfriendly
so I can say something like all my S3
buckets and then you can just tell
things using just uh conversational
English or I can say something like um
which
are part of my
lamb the
function
chain and it seems to get quite a lot I
frankly I don't even know how it knows
that these are part of the Lambda
function chain but it seems like it it
got a lot of them beyond the user
interface there's also a robust API for
those who wish to build Automation and
Tools around this data the system also
understands user permissions so as an
organization admin I can view all the
resources but for larger organizations
with specific permission requirements
users will will only see resources they
have access to this ensures security and
privacy while still providing valuable
insights so all these tools help provide
users a comprehensive and manageable
view of their plumey resources also if
you have your own data warehouse and
business intelligence tools you can
integrate data with Plum's tools with
your existing Data
Solutions okay we've reached the end of
the course you should now be able to
start using AI I to create
infrastructure more easily thanks for
watching